サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
はい それではよろしくお願いします
ちょっと長い時間苦労する羽目になります
ブッダの教えを世に広げることほど尊いことは存在しません
なぜならば お釈迦様だけ
すべての生命は平等であるということを説かれているのです
自分偉いという感じで生きるんじゃなくて
みんなに対して慈しみ
優しい心で生活しなさいと比丘たちに出家に入っているのは
あなたは鋸で切断されても
相手に対して嫌な気持ちを作るなよと
そんな風な教えは世に存在しないんです
人間のすべての問題に答えはそちらにあるんです
人間のせいで地球が泣いているんです
他の同族はものすごくひどい目に遭っているんです
地球上で存在している一番残酷な生命体は人間なんです
しかし 自分が何をやっているのかさっぱりわからない
科学者らしく自然を破壊しているのに
科学者らしく物事を見ないです
それで自分で壊してから何か手当を考える
それからそれにも反対する
そういう風な まるっきりもうまとめがいない人間に
本当に平和 平安の安穏のメッセージを与えたんです
人類歴史上初めて 人類は平等であるんだと
ただ 生物学的にカラスと犬は違うんだと
犬と猫は違うんだと 生き方すべて
しかし 人間が何であろうとも同じだと
だから人間の間で差別するなよと
ただ一種の生命体だと
そういうふうな教えですから
ずっとこの頭イカれてる人間が仏教に反対
反対 仏教だけ広げちゃったら困るんだと
戦えない 戦争することはできない
人のものを奪うことはできない
人を助けなくちゃいけない
競争はできなくなっちゃって
共存しなくちゃ それ嫌なんですね
みんな 頭イカれた獣のように手当たり次第全部潰して壊して生きたいんで
だからといって何を得るものはないんですね
歴史で皆様の学校の教科書でも褒め称えている偉いヒーローたちがいるでしょ
みんな人殺し屋でしょ
得たもの何かありますか？アレクサンダー大王やらもうナポレオンやら
もう何か得た？あのバカたちが
ただ殺して歴史に残っただけで
それも嘘でしょうに なんで殺し屋と書かないんですかね
だから優しく人に人を助ける人々はもう裁かれる
社会から追い出されるという
だからまあ 仏教はまあなかなか人気のない宗教になっています
あの最近 自分の国でテロ事件が起きちゃって
イスラム人もね 起きて次の日からお坊さん侮辱するのを始めたんです
私たちのせいだと 言って
アメリカの大使館 アメリカはもう直ちにお坊さんたちが結構アメリカビーズ持って入らないんだからね
すべて停止しちゃったんです
なんだこれはと ずっと喉に血が出るまでみんな仲良くしましょうと
別れるなよと それぞれ自分の宗教は平和で頑張りなさいと
そうしなきゃ我々は厳しいことをやりますよという風にお坊さんたちはずっと
あの国のリーダーたちだからね
政治家とは違ってね 国を率い出していて
のすけなお坊さんなんですよ
だからそう言われるんだから
この人々のせいでテロ行為が起きたということでね
政府もアメリカと組んで一生懸命お坊さんたちを
まあもう何といいますか
抑えるために社会から権力を全部奪ってやろうと
今必死で頑張っているんです
面白いですよ 人殺し屋が聖人になって人を殺すなかれと言った人が悪人にするというね
いまだにこの人間のイカれた獣の精神というのは治ってないんです
獣が支配している世界になっているんですね
で こういう風にちょっと強い口でこちらで日本から喋るんだけど
自分の国で喋ったらもうすぐ警察が来て
あんた多重嫌疑で逮捕しますよと
ということになるんです
しかし イスラム人の人々はもう最近ね
待ってみろよと お前らはみんな怯えて震えることにしますよと
一人残らず潰しますよと
それは大丈夫です そう言っちゃうと
それに際して答え出すなようなんですね
その人々は興奮させるなよと
暴走が悪いんだと そういう世界なんです
そこまで言ったのは まあ人的にもなんかすごく嫌なことをいっぱい受けているんだから
嫌っていうのは不公平なこと
残酷なこと 人々が地獄に陥ること来る場合は
まあ我々は出家だから
それは黙って見ていることはできないんですよ
お釈迦様に身を差し上げたら
もう我々は遺伝子まで変わっちゃうんです
普通の人とは違うんです
だから 知ってる人でも知らない人でも
例えば私みたいなくだらない人間にもね
これやめなさいと言っちゃうと
やめるしかないんですよ
もうそれでもやります
あんた誰ですか？と その力がないんです
昔 私は覚えてます 日本でかなり前ね
電車で満員で乗っていると
なんか嫌なことをしてサービス的な攻撃しようとしている男性なんですが
何人か来たケースあるんですね
ひと言葉言うんですよ
だからこのままビビっちゃって
ある人は酒飲んで酔っ払って
それなんでお前ら食い物ないからこの食いに来ているんではない
あれやこれや初めていいこと言ったら
酒もなくなっちゃって
ビビっちゃって すごく下がって
別なところに行って隠れて行く羽目になっちゃったんです
だからまあ出家したら遺伝子まで違いますよ
だからまあ我々は人々が不幸になることを見ると
もうどうしても遺伝的に黙っていられないんです
皆様には慈悲の瞑想はただのスローガンでしょう
我々にとってスローガンじゃないんです
それは我々の命なんです
それで生きているんです
金持ちになるために 有名になるために生きているわけじゃないんです
生きている 1 分 1 分でも慈悲を実践しようという気持ちで生きているんですね
ですから いろいろ言われるんですね
言われれば構いませんだけど
それにすられてもう金儲かりたい人々はね
権力にいる人々 それにすられて人類を破壊に陥れることっていうのは
まあちょっと黙って見ていられないんだから
ちょっと空調で喋りました
そこまで喋ったのは訳がありまして
皆様がブッダのメッセージをね
これは完璧 科学的なメッセージです
完璧に人間の道を教えることなんです
ただ頭で野球棒 バットでね
10回殴ったような感じで
わけもわからなくて どうせなんぼもわからなくて動いているような
この生き方やめて しっかりと目を開けて
自分で判断して 自分で選択
判断して善行を行って立派な人間になる道を教えているんだ
だから私はそれさらに厳しい言葉にするんですよ
形だけ人間ですけど みんな他の獣と何のも変わりがないんだと
だから仏教は形の人間が名実ともに本物の人間にしてあげようとしているんです
殴っても殴り返さないとかね
出家に入っているのは
もうノコギリで切られても生のまんまで怒るなよと
だからまあ そういうメッセージを世に広げていくことはね
かなりの闘いにはなります
そこで 私の力では力 精神的な力はいくらでもありますけど
しかし もう世の中でいろんな協力がないと活動はできないんですね
ものの見事に日本の皆様方は全面的に協力してくれるし
それから私にできない世俗的なことはね
すごい責任を持ってやっているし
ですから そういう皆様方は
世に存在する救国の功徳を行っていると
人類に役に立つことをやっているんだと
生まれてきたことで 何の無意味で死ぬんじゃなくて
この生きている間で生命に対して役に立つことをやって残して残しなんだということは
皆様にも自慢できることだと思います
善行というのはそういうことなんですね
ですから 今日のこの説法会
ブッダのメッセージを日本に広げることに対してのお布施がありまして
えっと 大泉孝さんが今日の会場費やらね
お布施を全部全額お布施いたしまして
ものすごい素晴らしい徳を積むことができました
ですから 私も自分個人的には心から感謝したいと
感謝する必要はない お布施した人はその功徳で
その瞬間からもう立派な心が清らかになって
立派な人間に変わってはいきますね
問題はありません で えーと
大泉さんの希望もありましてね
自分のご両親が幸福になりますようにと
また テーラワーダ教会の皆様方も
この功徳で この功徳の力で幸福になりますようにという
すごく意識高い 優しい慈悲の気持ちなんですね
ですから皆様 大泉 大泉さんのご両親も幸福でありますように
また 大泉さんの他の親戚の方々も幸福でありますように
早くもそういう皆様はね
心清らかになって 人格向上して解脱に達することができますようにとお誓いいたしますので 3
回サーブーサーブー  サーブーサーブー
それから今日のね 説法会にいらっしゃった方々は
いろんな遠くからいらっしゃっているんですからね
地方からね 皆様方にも
大泉さんがね 功徳を依拠していますので
教会の関係ある皆様方も今日参加する皆方
皆様方にもこの功徳をもって幸福になりますように
健康でいられますように
日々心が清らかになりますように
心から悪の感情がなくなりますように
解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたしますので
再び3回サーブーサーブーサーブー
はい ではこれでスライド
それから今日は結構初参加の方々もいますから
私の月例恒例の話になっちゃうと
あんまり難しくてね わけもわからなくなる可能性あります
だから今悩んでますけど
で 仏教は精密な観念とした完成した科学ですから
ちょっと難しいということは当然あります
なぜならば 信じなさいとかね
こうしたらこうなりますよと
理由なしの説明は一切ないんです
だからどうせ食べて生きることしか脳みそができてないんだからね
生命の だからちょっと違う次元のことを喋るとわからなくなりますし
そこはうまく使って人に迷信を強引に押し付けて宗教っていう
ものも世の中にあるんですね
仏教は宗教ではありません
しっかりと科学的に人生を自分の命を勉強している世界なんですね
はい 今日のテーマがこの世界が複雑
幸福は心配というね で
まず覚えてください 今日の話は本当は因果法則というブッダの教えに対して
一応基本的に喋りたいという計画なんですね
まあいくらかわかりやすいスライドを流してわからなくなったところで
普通初参加の方々にもわかりやすくは喋れますね
大体こんなのは誰だって知ってることだ
不安な世界から落ち着かない
だから我々は世界はすごく危険で不安だと思っているんですね
世間の起きることは 我々個人個人にはよくわからないんですね
なんでこうなっているのかとかね
だから安心できないんですね
だから そういうことで皆様の幸福が壊れているんです
世界のことをよくわからない
どうなるのかと 一番わかりやすく言えば
これはもうそんなに大げさな問題じゃないんだけど
いつ地震が起こるかわからないんですね
だからそればっかり考えちゃうと
いてもたってもいられなくなっちゃうんですね
どう研究したっても 地震が起こる起こる日とちょうどとかは科学者に計算できません
世間の動きもどんな風に動くかわからない
例えば 2 日ニュース見ない見ないでいると
3 日目で何がわからなくなっちゃうんです
それぐらいもう読めないように世の中変化しているんだから
もう不安でたまらなくなっちゃうんですね
それから経済状況はものすごく激しく
僕は犯罪が起こるは 自然災害あるわ
それから人と仲良し近所でちょっと知らない人が引っ越しちゃうと不安になっちゃう
特に外国人なんか住んじゃうと不幸になる
我々のアパートを貸してくれないんですよ
あんた外国人でアジア人ですよ
ダメといったことまで
だからそこは潜って いろんな方法でずっと長い間日本に住んでいるんです
実際 何か部屋貸してください
言っちゃうと もういくら保証人に来たからといって外国人だからダメよと言うんですね
だからなぜかというと
そういう人々は商売ですけど
本当のところは周りの人々は性格が悪いということでしょ
だからアパートとかそういう業者業者の方々にも仕方がない
あの何の責任ですか？もちろんその方は外国人はダメって言ってるんだよと
はい アパートに住んでる他の人々はダメというんですけどね
という話なんですね だから誰しないと誰でと言っても
皆様にとってはなんか隣
外国人とか誰か行くしたらもう怯えちゃうんですね
そういうことで いろいろ皆様の幸福を壊す原因がありますね
ですから 世の中を調べると
あるのは嫌になることばかりでね
で 豪雨になっても 換気になってもね
などでも 周りの騒音 車の渋滞などをなどなどですね
困るためなら 悩むためなら何でもいいんですね
なんか私たちの心が壊れてるんですよ
車に乗って高速道行ったら渋滞
それだけでも あー嫌だこれはねとイライラする
ちょっと騒音があったら
あー嫌だ これ病気になるんだ
もうもうもう寝られないんだとかね
訴える 面白いことというのは
おばあさんたちから この隣の幼稚園なんか買っちゃうと
もう反対する うるさいとかね
よくおばあちゃんでそんな文句を言うことを
だから普通だったら子供はうるさいのは当たり前で
子供の声は強烈で響くっていうことはごく当たり前のことですけど
俺々は壊れちゃって これ我慢できなくなるんですね
腹が立ってしまうんですね
まとめてみると まるまるのせいで私は不幸だということですね
じゃあわかりやすく言います
あんたは幸福ですか？と
まあどうでしょうねとかね
答えたとしましょう なんであんた不幸ですかねと
まるまるのせい あれで隣の家の
あるいは隣のアパートで子供たちがいっぱいいて
うるさくて遊ぶんだとかね
あるいは自分がまあ建物で
10階で9階で子供がいて
もう夜泣くはもう嫌だとかね
だから まるまるのせいで私は不幸だっていうスタンスで
立場で人間が生きているんです
これは皆様の個人的な問題じゃないんです
人類がそういう生き方をやっています
だから私は皆様 日本人が聞いているとか
皆様を狙い狙い撃ちでいろいろ悪口を言うんだけど
皆様はそうじゃなくて
これは人類の問題を喋ってるんだと思ってください
で 私の日本人のことを置いておいてくださいと思ったら
皆様は日本人であることを否定しているんです
えっ 間違ったね 皆様方は人間であることを否定しているのです
では 日本人になる前に人間なんですね
だから人間で日本人ですね
それだけのことで 批判的な言葉はすべての人類に共通するものです
だから日本人だけではなくて
どんな国の人もまるまるのせいで不幸やとかね
例えば昔 何年前かわからない
中国で暴動を起こしちゃったんですね
日本人 反日運動で 日本人のせいで中国はダメになっているんだと
どうしますかね それは人間という生命体なんですね
あの日本のデパートとかってね
結構品物はいいし もうやり方はすべて日本的なやり方で
これはかなり人気あって
かなり儲かっていたんですね
いや 何か一言葉 日本の頭イカれた政治家が言ったことで
それで中国でも誰でもひどい暴動を起こしちゃったりした
昔のニュースで覚えているんです
最近はニュースを読まないことになってるんだから
今のニュースは何もわからない
そういうことでね 誰だってこのまるまるのせいで私は不幸だっていうふうな立場をとってますね
そのポイントは他人に指を指すことですね
いつでも何かしる他人に指を指す
例えば自分の体病気になったところで調べたら
もうあれが悪いこれが悪いって言われると
食べ物のせいだ 犯人は食べ物なんですね
食った自分じゃないんです
イライラして精神的にちょっと問題があったら
まあいい 東京に住んでるから
東京の人々は悪いんです
不幸の原因は外にあると思うことで
幸福を目指して外の世界と戦って打ち勝たなくてはいけなくなりますね
そこまで皆様の頭ではなくて
人間の頭は動かないんです
じゃあ 日本の例で 東京のアパートに住んでいる人は
すぐ精神的な問題を抱えて寝られなくなっちゃって
精神科に行って薬飲む羽目にもなりましたと
そこで原因を調べたら
この環境 東京は 20時間寝ないんだからね
はい 環境のせいで ということになるでしょ
その人にある答えは このアパートに住みたければ
東京と戦わなくちゃいかんですね
みんな 9時半になってくると
すべて車やら全部止めなさいよと
テレビなどなど消しなさいよと
何やってるんだと 私はちょっともう精神的にストレスかかってるんだよっていう態度でしょ
自己よりは世界は強大なので
おそらく負けるんですね
勝てっこはないんです
他人に許させても それを論理的に理解してください
だから私 住んでいる家の前にもすごい大きいアパート
でっかいビルがありましてね
ある時間決まってる時間に子供たちは外に出てまあ遊んでいるんですよ
すごく骨に来るんですね
音は 年取ってくると てっきり私もわかったんだ
なんでおばあさんたちたちは子供たちに文句を言うのかと
耳はそれほど私も耳がすごく弱いんですね
でも子供がキャーって言っちゃうと
骨がずっと響くんです
だから だから子供の口を閉じてやろう
そういう人はもうどうにもならん
私はその人一緒にもう一人いたんだから
私はそれを冗談で入れ替えようと
じゃあ私は今度は法律を作らなくちゃいけないんだけど
どういう法律とかって言ったら
子供は大きい声でしゃべってはいけませんと
だからそう言った途端
いかにバカバカらしいかとはわかるでしょうね
子供は大きい声で喋ってるわけじゃなくて
子供の声はあれなんです
だからそれは我々の骨まで響くっていうことは
だから遺伝子に文句を言わなくちゃいけないんです
大人は子供の叫ぶ声で反応するように遺伝子が成り立っているんだから
仕方がないでしょうに
頭がいかれているんだから
私みたいにちょっと冗談
まあこれは子供に対する法律だよと
今日からなんて大きくしゃべったら
もうもう法律違反で まあなんとかなんとかとか
で まあそれ自体でっていうのは馬鹿馬鹿らしいでしょ
だから私が言いたいのは
子供はうるさいという言葉ほど馬鹿馬鹿らしいことは世の中でないんです
ですから 我々は他に指さすならば
その人は 100%ではなくて 300%で負けているんです
勝てっこはないんです
世界に向かって ですから
世界で幸福に達する人は稀です
ごくごくまれ 何が起きても私
私 個人的なことなんですけど
何が起きても笑いますよ
それはだから前の例なんですよ
買い物して帰ってくると
なんかちっちゃな子供がギャーとなんとか誰かに喋ったかなんとかなんですね
それで歩いている私の骨がドルルルってなっちゃったの
そこで私は客観的にそれを知っていて
これでちょっとネタ作ろうかなと
ああ 嫌だなということじゃないんです
だから私にとってはすごく笑い話で笑っちゃいます
そういうわけで 幸福になる人々は稀なんで
みんな頭いかれているんです
貸すはすもない戦いに挑んでいるんです
はい なんでそんな風に人類が頭いかれたんですかね？変でしょ
ブッダの話を聞かない限り
誰だってこの穴に落ちています
だから仏教を広げることというのは
とても素晴らしいことになっているんです
はい そこで前提があるんですね
頭おかしいんだから 私は前提っていうのはアプライヤルですけど
言えばあの前もって決めた決めた考え
仏教的にそれは成り立ちません
前もって何か考えを決めることできないんです
データを取ってから決めなくちゃいけない
数学ではそういうアプライヤルできてきて
そこから例えば一直線の定義がありまして
一直線であるというと証明することはできない
円とはこういうものだと言うんであって
それは円であると証明することは
それは全然問題はないんだけど
じゃあそう決めましょうということで
それで数学が成り立つんですね
1 たす 1は2であると
それは証明する必要はないんです
実際に証明しようとすると
1 たす 1は2ということになり立てなくなっちゃうんです
成り立つ場合もそうでない場合もありますね
だから数学でいえば 1 たす 1はおそらく 2 でしょう
そうすると変でしょ あるいはまあ
ちょっと英語で言います INMOSTcases
1 プラス 1 イズツー IN most cases
例外 exception があって
there are rare cases that you do not get one plus one equal
to という風に言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
で 変ですね 数学成り立たないね
数学の方で置いておいてください
問題はそれは問題ではありません
しかし 人類においては
生きることにおいては
前提は成り立たないんです
前提が定めたものがなければ
すべて不確定になるんです
じゃあ生きることは一切すべて不確定の理論だよと言っちゃうと
皆様に理解できる？認めたい？認めたくないでしょ
はい だから前提書きます
順番で 1私には問題ありません
だって人のせいだからね
2 幸福に生きられることは生まれつきの権利ですと
これ変です 別に不幸になって何が悪い？誰が決めた？必ず幸福にならなくちゃと思ってるから
こういう問題が起こるんです
まあ不幸でもいいやっていうことになっちゃうと
子供がうるさいことは問題にならないでしょ
寝ようとしたら 暴走族が今は東京でないんだけど
オートバイでギャーギャーギャーギャーって言っちゃう
あのあのマフラーのあれも変えているんで
あの連中がもっと大きい声出そうと思ってね
だから自分が寝られなくてイライラ別にと思っちゃうよ
それだけでしょ 寝られないんだったら寝ないでいるぞと
なんでそれに文句を言う？いえ
ぐっすり寝ることは自分の権利であると
私から見れば 若い連中がね
あんなすっごい音を出して
もうスピードで走り回ることも
その人たちの権利なんですけど
その人は自分のもう溜まってるエネルギーは何かで発散したいんですよ
その場合は大人に迷惑をかけなきゃ意味がないんです
まだまだ子供だから だからその立場から見ると
別に勝手にやれ それだけですよね
だから私は生まれつき幸福なんだか
まあまあ そういう生まれつきの権利だと思っていることは前提です ３
私は幸せにならない理由は外の世界にあります
私に問題ないでしょ あなたのせい
環境のせい あれであれで不幸せ
騒音のせいで不幸せっていう風に言ってるんだから ４
私の怒り 落ち込み 苦しみはあなたのせいです
これは堂々と言ってますね
あなたのせいですと 奥さんのせいで旦那が落ち込んだりする
旦那のせいで奥さんが落ち込んで悩んだりするし
言っちゃってるんですよ
子供のことで悩んでるお母さんたちがいるしね
教育のことで悩んでるとかね
だから私のその人は幸福を感じてないでしょ
だから落ち込んだり 怒ったり
文句を言ったり 警察に訴えたり
あれやこれやとごちゃごちゃやってるんですね
それは必ずもあなたのせいということなんです
うん 私も一つ言っちゃおうかな
私もあまり食欲がないんだよ
皆様のせいです 責任持ちなさい
そんな話でしょ 結局は
はい 次に行きます これから難しくなります
知識人は理由 原因などを探す
探すんだけど見つかってないことは面白いね
今 私が今までこの序論としてね
話に入る前に言った このわかりやすいセクションすら世間では聞くことはできなくなっている
原因を究明 することで再発防げますね
そこまではいいんです
だから原因究明っていうのは
仏教用語では因果法則ということになります
仏教は因果法則の教えです
それはもう明らかにしています
ブッダは何を説かれたか
因縁によって物事が生まれると説かれたんです
軽く聞こえますけど ものすごい難しい真理なんです
それで全ての人間の信仰は否定しているんです
否定する必要ない これは嘘ということになるんです
神が作ったとかね それは成り立たない
原因 因果法則です 知識
科学世界も物事の因果関係を探す
科学者は因果法則はわかってないんだけど
なんでこうなるの？なんでこうなるの？なんでこうなったの？というところを調べるんですね
これはなんで？っていうところで
原因 リングはなぜ落ちたのかと
その話は長いですけど
わかりませんだけどね
で そこで因果法則を発見しているんです
いまだに科学世界は 我々は因果法則を大事に
それが真理だと思っている世界だと言わないです
まだまだ遅れているんです
医学であろうか 宇宙の研究であろうか
もうなんでくだらんことをなんでやっても
因果法則なんですよ 因果法則無視して宇宙船飛ばせないでしょうに
スペースステーション作れないでしょうに
飛行機は飛ばないんでしょうに
自転車はこげないんでしょう
自転車考えて作った人もあらゆる因果法則を考えたんです
しかし 間違っててもすべて因果法則ですねとは気づかないんです
自転車のあれ開発したバカも
神様は私に特別な能力を与えてくれたと
とんでもないバカなんです
美しく歌える人は これは神様から与った能力だと
そんな一言を聞いたら
聞いたら それから私はその人をすごい上手だなと褒めていて
それから切るんです はい
さようなら お前バカ だからね
細胞が構成する場合は
その遺伝子の組み立てでものすごくもうなんて音を出すセクションがしっかりと健康に出来上がっている
それだけで我々の 私の場合はそこら辺は作りが良くないんです
だから音は出ないんです
そこである程度で歌手歌う能力がある人々はまたハチャメチャ訓練するでしょうに
それで筋肉ができちゃって
声帯が出来上がっちゃって
呼吸の練習もしちゃって
どのように決まった音を出せるのかと
だから訓練の結果でしょうに
一切訓練もしないで歌手になった人はいる？いるわけないでしょうに
しかし それは神様からいただいた特別なプレゼントだと
神バカですかね 一人にだけそういう能力をあげて
他はあげてない 一人は超美人で美男で生まれるようにして
他の人にはあげないという
すごい残酷ですね だから残酷なことを言ってるんだっていうことに
それは気づかないんですね
はい 原因究明は客観的で
事実を発見するためにある正しい方法で
だからといって この原因究明っていうのは正しい方法なんです
原因を探してください
しかし ブッダは因果法則こそが理解しがたい難解な教えであると教えています
科学者のこのちっぽけな幼稚的な因果法則じゃないんです
複雑でわかりにくいようと
いろいろ機械とか組み立て子の子供のおもちゃとかありますね
何か玉を入れたら ぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってガチで止まるとかね
あるいは車入れたら車自分勝手で開いて閉じて見ていると楽しいんだけどね
因果法則はいたって簡単にわかりますね
そんな単純じゃないんだと
はい これからちょっと難しくなるんだから
今日は初めて講演を聞いている方々のことも考えて
ちょっと物語を言います
因果法則は何回というポイントで
えーと もう相当前の話
大阪どこかの学校で 小学...中学生かなね
子供が人殺しちゃった
揉めてる自分の学校 同じ学校の同じクラスの人を殺しちゃったんです
で 殺しただけじゃない
首を切っておいたんです
まず えっ？そんなことあり得るか？と
そこで当時で各テレビ番組で何時間も使って喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ
犯人捜すんです もうその子どもやとも
もう僕は簡単に分かったんだけど
だから犯人探しは面白くなくなっちゃったんですね
殺した子供見つかりましたから
それからさらに原因 原因究明に行くんですね
あった迷惑 マスコミが何もデータないのに
あの家にいて 外からもうカメラ 100台ぐらい抱えて
あの人々の生活はできないし
引っ越しする羽目になっちゃうし
あちらに行ったら これ警察の周りでカメラ構えてまた喋る
データないっていうことははっきりしますね
なんかどこかのテレビ局で
どこかに事件が起きちゃうと
あるアナウンサーが行って
その場所に場所は警察は立ち入り禁止のテープ張ってますけど
それでこういう風になった
こういう風になったと泣いたりまでする男性なんですけど
こんなことで金儲けて食べてるんでしょうかと
人に嘘を言っちゃって
はい それでテレビで知識人たち
いろんなもう医学の知識人たち
一流の何々さんとかね
精神 あのサイコロジーの一流の何々
犯罪心理学の一流の何々とかね
来て喋るわ 喋るわ 喋るわ
当時で私も日本の社会勉強していた時だから
もう苦労しながら聞いていたんだけど
今は至って単純にテレビを消す
もう私の寿命が直ちに短くなったんだから
くだらないゴミを入れたくはない
それでいろいろ理由を出すでしょ
1親のしつけに問題があったとか
ほとんどお父さんは家になかったとか
偉そうに言う この人々はブッダの方法を知らないんですね
父親が家にいなかったからやと言った途端
ケース３つ４つ出してほしい
ブッダはケースミスよしではなくて
それは確定した真理でなければいけないと
ですから どんな子供の住んでいる家でも
父親がいなかったら その子供は人殺しに行かなくちゃいけない
でも父親がいなかった
いなかったからといって人殺しに行く子供はまずないんですね
だからあれはくだらない原因
それから学校でちょこちょこといじめられたり
自分だけの世界に閉じ込んでいたんだと
だからやとそう言うんですね
これで西洋の心理学からいろいろ引用したり
わけのわからない単語でしたけどね
英語で言ったらわかるんだけど
日本語に訳すとするとそれもわからなくなっちゃうんだからね
カタカナそうだから で
見ていて では学校で自分だけの世界を作っているのは
いる子は誰だって犯罪に行くならば
それは有効な理論なんです
そうじゃないでしょ？私は大学卒業するまで自分の世界を作っていたんです
犯罪はしていないんです
昆虫一匹でも子供の頃から殺したことはないんです
それはお母さん怖いんだからなんです
一回だけメダカ取ろうとしたんだ
弟と それも殺すためでも何でもなくて
弟と内緒で瓶にこのメダカを取って育てちゃいましょうよと
弟も乗ってきて そこで母親の着る長いのがあったんだから
母親どこ見るか で 水が流れるところでこれ入れちゃって
なんとなく中にメダカが入るようにしちゃったんですね
後ろを見たら母親にバレちゃったんです
それで終わり 怒られたこと
それっきりやってないんです
だから でも私は私の世界を作っていたんです
それで犯罪はしていないんです
だからだいたい子供はそういうのいくらでもいるんです
それでまたいじめられたと
いじめられたからといって人殺す？みんな
それもあてにならない
で その子はもしかしてもともと考えはおかしいかったと
物事は正しく判断していないんだと
それ私はあんた嘘を言うな
あんた その子供に会って面接したんですかと
それはダメでしょ だったら子供の考えは変やっていうこと
どうやって言うんですかね
それで何か書いた作文とか何とかとか出す
でも作文で変なこと書いちゃう
その子は犯罪に行く それも役になりたくない
大体ちょっと明るい子供たちっていうのは
作文書いちゃうと なんか先生を怒らせて困らせる文章が書けるならば必ず書きますよ
わざわざと あれって子供のゲームであって
先生が怒って困って悩んでる顔を見たいんです
子供は裏でやったそうというだけ
まあいろいろ原因言うは言うは言うは
何を見つからない この再発防止にならなかったね
それからも子供たちの間で犯罪は起きますよ
私の仏教 それが複雑なんです
そんな馬鹿に原因究明できるわけじゃないんです
だからいい加減因果法則を知っているんだけど
私は原因究明してみせると
やめなさいと 仏教徒にあんたできるわけじゃないんだと
これ難しいだと理解してください
はい それで例えばその子の母親が厳しかった
子供に対してと 母親が厳しくなると
子供は無数の反応をする
決まってないんです すべて不確定です
母親は厳しいんだから落ち着く子もいる
母親は厳しすぎちゃって暗くなる子もいる
母親は厳しいんだから反抗する子もある
反抗もその子が決めるんです
宿題やらない 登校を拒否する
なんとかなんとか 隣の家の窓にも石を投げてやる
あるいは万引きしてやるとかね
だから反抗に行く子供も決める反抗っていろいろ
しかし 人を殺してやるっていうところまではいかないね
でもそれも一つある 先生たちの態度が悪かったら
またそれも一つ だから必ず 1 たす 1 は 2 という感じで
先生の態度が悪く悪くなると
子供は犯罪をするという風にならないね
それも一つの原因であることは確かなんです
友達はいなかった だからこれっていうことは結論がつけられない
それもなんとか原因になる
そういうわけで 一個の現象に対しての原因というのは無数に無限に見つかるんです
それでもブッダ以外は答え出せないんです
なぜかというと 原因に人がどんな反応するのかということも不確定なんです
先生の態度が悪かったら
生徒の子供がどんな反応するかと
決まった反応じゃないんです
そういうわけで 世の中
経済状況が悪くなったとかね
それはどういうことかと
くだらんですよ 誰も見つかりっこはない
株がガクンと下がったら
こういう理由やとか 一つも当てにならない
しかし みんな専門家なんです
喋っている人々は 例えば経済学部博士
ノーベル賞まで取ったからといって世界の経済を良くすることできる？できない
日本だけ なんか一人素晴らしい
なんか神様みたいな経済学がいるという話がいたんだけど
彼が経済ビジョンを持っていていて
誰もみんなに拒否されています
けど そのビジョンを私が読んでいたら
なるほどすごいと これ実行したら人類が幸せになるんだよと
だから当然日本社会からも追い出される
あなたは仲間ではありませんと
こちら殺し合いの仲間だからという感じで
はい そういうことで経済学者いるんだけど
経済的なアドバイスはするんだけど
ろくな結果がない 政治やってる人々は専門家のアドバイスを聞いてるんだけど
ろくな結果がない しかし
世の中はみんな因果法則を探してはいるんです
そこまで探すんだったら見つかっているがさいよと言いたいんだけど
見つからないと ということ
こうだからこうなったと
ブッダの因果法則というのははっきり言っています
これがあるからこれがあるとお釈迦様はまず言うんです
次にこれがなかったらこれがないんだよと
あれはブッダ以外言えないんです
例えば母親が 厳しくて
また仕事で家にほとんどないと
夜しかいないと それで母の愛情がなくなったから
この子供は犯罪者になったと
と言うならば 母の愛情があって育てる人々
子供たちが一人一人も犯罪を起こす必要はないんです
でもやってるでしょ いろんな国で
日本だけではなくて だからAがあるからBがあると言ったら
A がなかったらBがないということは一緒です
それが言えるのはブッダだけです
だからその中でもお釈迦様は我々に解脱に達するために必要な因果法則を語ったんです
世の中のことはそれほど具体的に説明しなくて
まあちょこちょこ言うんです
お釈迦様は政治やるならば
こういうふうにやってくださいと言ってやる文章はあります
その通りにやるならば
どんな国も幸せで豊かになる
はっきりします ブッダの言葉だから
民主主義的に政治やるならば
この項目を守ってくださいと七つの項目出してるんです
守ったら完璧な民主主義になるのです
でもブッダの教えだからもう効くもんじゃないね
できるだけ批判しなくちゃあかんね
そういうふうに思っている人間が
そういうわけで 私はここまでブッダのことをものすごく宣伝するのは
ブッダは完全たる解脱に達して語った言葉
すべて完璧な真理からなんです
もう揺らぎないんです
それで私たち一般人が
例えばどこかで子供を誘拐された
すると 子供を持っている親は誰だって怯えちゃって
自分の子供が誘拐されない
されては困るという気持ちになる
だから 誘拐された原因究明しなくちゃいけない
確かにやるんだけど また誘拐が起こる
最近ないんだけどね ある時期あったんです
そこで大学生の女の子が殺される
別れた恋人に そういうケースもあったでしょ
それで誰だって自分の子供が大学生になったら殺されて欲しくないでしょ
だから大学生の子を持っている親たちがちょっと緊張しちゃって
うちの子はどうなるのかということで
それでその人々にあんたこうしなさい
それで問題起きませんと
ということはできなくなっているんです
難しいんです 例えば女の子は恋人を作るなよって決めていい？あの年で恋人を作るでしょ
誰だって じゃあ恋人ある子はみんな殺される？ないでしょうに
はい そういうふうに私たちは偉そうに世界理解してやるぞと思って頑張ってるんだけど
あまりにも複雑で 人間の脳みその能力では把握できないんです
はい 次に行きます そこまで一人喋ったのは
初めて話を聞く方々にも
なんかこれ仏教の説法ですか？ってびっくりするでしょうね
人間の問題はこれなんです
で 私はあまりあの すっごく勢いで書いちゃったんだから
あと日本語の単語を考えることできなかったんです
で 英語で説明します イミディエイトコースアンドプロミネントコース
イミディエイトはとても近しい近い原因とプロミネントというのは派手に見える原因
じゃあ例を出します ハモに刺されて人は亡くなる
それは結果 一般人には刺されたことは死の原因
一般人にとってなんでこの人は死んじゃうの？だってハモに刺されたんだからでしょ
わからない このバカって言うんですね
しかし 医者は大量出血などなどの別なことを死因だと発表しますね
肺に穴があって出血し
大量出血 だから心臓に穴が開けて
心臓が機能停止して死にましたと
なんで医者が刃物のせいで死んだと言わないんですか？医者の因果法則別なんです
なぜこの人死んだのかと
なぜかというと 刃物に刺される全ての人間が死にませんね
みんな死ぬ いくらでもいるでしょうね
私の国で 今私の国とは言いたくはないんだけどね
あの誰かさんの国 である地方があって
漁師さんたちなんですよ
だから我々みんなあの地方に
あの村に怖いという気持ちを持ってるんです
だから仕事は海に行って魚を取ることをですねと言って
切ってさばいて売って生活している
だからみんなものすごい鋭いこの刃物を持ってるんで
日常所持するものなんです
それでこの切るっていうことはね
毎日の仕事なんです そこで酒飲んで二人ちょっとでも口喧嘩になったら
みんな刃物持ってるでしょ？やっちゃいます
そこで手あちらこちらで当たってすごい怪我しちゃうんだけど
あんまりそういうこと言ってもその気もないんですね
それで面白いことは その地方の人が出家していて
別な宗派の人でしたけど
私と一緒に生活することにある時間になったんです
まあ 1年ぐらいですね
それでその人がすごい
この我々は絶対使わない単語を普通に使う
品のない で 普通に生活
え？って なんでそんな言葉を使うといったら
え？自分の地方ではこれが普通で敬語だと
え？と思ったんです それでその人言うんです
あちら行ったらね こちら辺でもう傷口があって
ここら辺で傷口があって
ここら辺 胸 横に刃物 そんなのいくらでもいるんだよと
それも普通だと ですから
私は言いたいのは 刃物にやられたからといって
全ての人類が死ぬわけじゃないんです
だから医者は死んだ原因は別な原因で言うんです
それで分かりましたね
因果法則の問題は 医者はイミディエイトコースを発表します
一番死に至った一番の理由
イミディエイトコースというんです
それでは一般人がプロミネントコース
派手な原因です 刺されたこと派手でしょ
大騒ぎするでしょ だから一般人にとっては因果法則
なんでまるまるさん死んだのか
刃物に刺されて死にましたと一般人が発表するんだけど
専門家は？大量出血して死にましたというんです
そういうわけで もうわかるでしょう
イミディエートコース
プロミネントコース イミディエートというのは
本当に 例えば人は自分の首を絞めても
首を絞めたから死にませんよ
酸欠で死ぬんです だから首を絞めることはプロミネント
派手な原因 酸欠死というのは本当に死んだ原因で
一番原因が起きてすぐに死んだ
だからイミディエート
一番興味のない原因 世界は因果法則
科学者もね 因果法則と言いながら因果法則と言ってないんだけど
原因究明しましょうと言いながら
大体このプロミネントコース
イミディエートコースしか見ません
そんな単純じゃないんです
あらゆる原因があるんです
人が包丁で刺された場合は
なんでそういうことになったのかと
複雑なケースいっぱいあるんです
そこで刺されるようになっちゃうと
誰だって身を守る そこでその人はなんで間違った身を守ることをやったのかと
さすれば 例えば例えば手でも出しちゃったら手が切られちゃって
それで大騒ぎになって一族になるでしょうに
出せなかった 手を守っちゃったんです
だからそういうこともそこをまとめなくちゃいかんのです
仏教的に言えば そいつの過去の業も考えなくちゃかんです
過去の業も割り込んできて
そういう条件を作ってくれたっていうことまで
一般世界には業ってないんだからね
考えは そういうわけで
原因っていうのは一つではありません
現象は無数の因と縁の結果なんです
はい もう一つわかりやすい例え出します
花は見事に咲いているという現象
タイトル原因探しましょう
なんで原因はなんでしたね
なんである花 この花 なんで見事に咲いてますかね
見事っていうのは私は書いてないんだけど
かっこよく すごく美しく
花びらにも問題なく 綺麗に元気いっぱいで咲いている
それに原因があります
じゃあ言える？春先で空気が暖かいから
嘘じゃないんだけど それだけ
土に適切な栄養がある
当たり前ね それだけ原因
品質の良い種だから 庭師はプロです
だから いくらでも原因見つかりますよ
そういうのはこの 今はイミディエートコースでもプロミネントコースでもないんです
そういうこと 例えば反対に入れちゃえばちゃうと
春先で空気が暖かから暖かいから花が元気いっぱいで咲いたよと言ったってもそうですかね
春先で暖かい空気になっちゃうと
どんな花でもそうすると当然元気いっぱい咲かなくちゃいけないんです
そうでない場合もありますね
逆 次 土に適切 土に栄養があったからといって完璧に花が咲く保証もない
たまたま栄養がそれほどなくても
かっこよく咲く花もいるんですね
だからどちらかとちょっと文句言えるんですよ
しかし それ全てを欲しいんですね
結局は だから私のポイントは
花が綺麗に咲いたからって偉そうに原因知ってますよと言わないでください
いろいろ はい それで仏教の用語
原因に加えて条件もあるんです
原因だけじゃないんです
条件 殺草がなかった 例えば
その花が育てたところで
周りは殺草がなかった
殺草があった それ一つ条件なんですね
必ず殺草があってはならないということじゃない
条件 共存できる仲間の植物もあったとかね
だからそれは条件だけ
花は種を蒔いたら育ちますよ
それで その花の植物さんに気に入る仲間がいる
植物の間で仲間がいますよ
その気に入る仲間も周りに植えておくと元気になるという
これは元気になる それは条件なんですね
ただ 水をあげなくちゃいけないでしょ
水をあげると言ったっても
水をあげちゃえばいいわけじゃないんです
条件がありますね  1 日何回か
どれぐらいか 量とかね
条件もあります ね 水は適量
適時でしたって それも必要ですね
虫たちの攻撃はなかった
土の中に良い微生物が
いたな いたなどもあります
だから たった花が咲いたっていうことにどれくらい原因があるのかと
どれぐらい条件があるのかと
土の中で生き物が一生ですけど
それもありすぎはダメなんですね
あの目が見えない なんとかいるんですね
なんて言いますか ミミズです
えっ？ミミズ ミミズではなくて
あのネズミのモグラ えっ？モグラ
モグラも土の中いるんだから
モグラ来たら困りますね
ミミズはいくらいたっても問題はないんですけどね
それからあのカビとかね
キノコのいろんな種類ですね
土の中にあった方がいい場合もあって
まずい場合もあります
はい そういうことで 私は今皆様に言いたがっているのは
誰だって知ってる言葉
綺麗に花が咲いてますね
なんででしょうか？と聞いちゃうと答えられないです
じゃあ何もわからない
わからないわけでもないんです
でも 言い尽くすことは不可能
できません 科学者するのは一つの原因を特別環境で実験してみるんです
だから 科学研究で出てくるものはほとんどあんまりうまくいかないんです
例えば ひじきは体に悪いという話がありましてね
それで科学者はひじきを取ってきて
成分分解して 体に悪い青酸カリとか成分
海のものだからね だから当然海の野菜っていうのは必ず毒を持ってますよ
で それでも我々は食べている
で これ食べたらすごい危険という場合
これおかしいんです なぜならば
その人が死ぬところになるまでは
大体まあ 100キロキロぐらいひじき食べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
誰も食べませんね  8キロぐらいは
でも発表しちゃう 納豆を食べたら健康にいいとか発表しちゃうとみんな乗るんです
乗るなよ そんなことに
納豆のある一つの成分を調べて
それはすごい健康にいい
他の成分はどうしますかね？あのカビはどうしますかね
体の中カビだらけになりますよ
あまりにも食べると 納豆はあの朝ご飯にまあ 5箱ぐらい
あるいは入れてそれだけ食べると
昼ご飯にはじゃあ 15箱を食べましょうとかね
まあ 2日でしょうね 命は
それだったら だから我々仏教の立場から科学も当てにならないと
あなたの助けになりませんと言うんです
なぜならば 世界は因果法則は知り尽くしてない
ん？戻ったっけ？うん
戻ってない 美しく花が咲いた理由原因 1個を示すことはできないのに
だから 1個これは原因だと言えないでしょ
だからみんなイミディエートコースかプロミネントコースだけで納得するんです
これは人間の問題なんです
何々さんがあれ 包丁で刺されて死にましたよと
一般人はそれで まあ研究者はレポート出して忘れちゃう
裁判に呼ばれたら またレポートを読みながら
傷の大きさ 刺されて何時間経ったのかと
その時間でどれぐらい血液が出血したのか
それで脳にどんな影響
そういうのを説明するだけで
それで犯人 この人は犯人だと決めることはできなくなる
それは警察は別な原因を持ってくる
この包丁は この人の家であったもの
この店で買ったもの この領収書と
で 包丁にはこれ 本人の血痕を混じっていた遺伝子を調べたら
これはこの人の犯罪者の遺伝子であったとかに
あるいはこの人の指紋が入っていたとか
そういうふうに警察は別な物語
因果法則 物語を作る いろいろです
大変複雑ですよ 世の中は
すべては神 仏性などの一因にまとめようとする邪見があります
これは邪見です すべては神が決めるんだから
そのまま放っておけと
なんで人は包丁される？それは神様がそう決めたんだから
明らかにそういうの一因ではないんです
発見できる原因を調べて調整してみても
期待する結果が得られることはことには保証はありません
ですから がんにならないようにこうしましょう
子供が犯罪しないようにこうしましょう
子供は投票投棄を拒否するしないためにこうします
いっぱいありますね アドバイス
交通事故をゼロにするためにこうします
ありますね  1ヶ月間 交通安
交通安全なんとか運動
笑ってしょうがない 私は笑っちゃいます
はい  1ヶ月間終わったら元気で頑張ってください
好きな放題と もう 地震のね
ハザード訓練がいるわあるわあるわ
それも地震が起きた時は身を守るために
でも守れない人は結構いる
津波が出たらハザードになるでしょ
でも津波で流されます
あれほどテキストあるのに
あれほどマニュアルあるのに
あれほど取扱説明書があるのに
なんでこの世界は一つ問題消えてないでしょ
ただ ヨーロッパ アメリカでも突然無差別殺人事件が起こりますね
解決した？いつ起こるかわからない
そういうわけで 世の中の話は当てにならんだからね
私は言いたいのはブッダの話聞きなさいと
そういうものをお釈迦様は見事にこういうすっぴったの問題に答えてあります
因と縁は複雑 無数ですから
世界は複雑です じゃあどう世界を理解しましょうというならば
ブッダはこれを答えで出しています
それだけじゃない 文句あったら言ってみてというのです
私たちは様々なトラブルが起きたら
原因究明に頑張って何か一つ二つを見つけて解決しようとする
原因 しかし 世界は良い方向に進展しそうもないんですね
原因と条件が無数なので
別な方法を考えるべきです
皆様 世界やっている方法ではなく
人類の問題を解決するためには別な道を発見しなくてはいけないです
はい それで仏教の因果法則になると
誰もやってない エクスターナルインターナルコーススで 2つ分けられるんです
外の原因と内の原因という
これは専門用語がありますよ
お釈迦様の言葉でアジャッタヘーとバヒッダヘーと
まずは英語の単語とか出してみたら
なんかびっくりするでしょう
エクスターナルコースス
インターナルコースス
お釈迦様は何のことなくおっしゃっていることです
どんな現象にもエクスターナルアンドインターナルコーススという 2つあります
コーススだけではなくて
インターナルコンディション
エクスターナルコンディションもまた 2種類あるんです
条件 そこでバヒッダヘーと
エクスター 外の原因の管理は難しい
理解しましょう 楽に生きられます
例えば今暑いでしょ？今ではなくてね
今の時期 暑い それは苦しいでしょ？暑くなっちゃうと
だから苦しくなったのはなぜ？周りが暑いから
では 周りの暑さが内なる原因
外の原因 外の原因ね だって私は太陽は来るようにして暑くしたわけじゃないんだからね
それは管理できない 皆様方
どう踏ん張っても環境は出席することは無理不可能
アジャッタヘーとは管理できます
インターナルは管理できます
いわゆる暑くなって反応したのは自分の体でしょ
そちらで管理できますね
冷たい水をかぶっていたり
冷たいタオルをかけたり
帽子をかぶったり etc
いろいろできますね 今なんかリュックサックにも扇風機がついてるものをコマーシャルで見たんだけどね
まあリスナーととかと面白いんだけどね
なんか頭に入れないか
かぶってるとちっちゃな扇風機が回ってるんです
そういうところではあまり違和感ないんだけどね
電車に乗っちゃうとずっと扇風機回ってるんですよね
ちょっと違和感感じたら
すごい普通に見慣れないことだから
みんなやっちゃえばどうってことないんだけど
それでもいたって単純にわかるでしょ
世にある問題に 自分に起こる問題に
インターナルコーススを管理しなさいと
内なる原因を管理しなさいと
えーと ページ数は今日何も書いてないな
半分ぐらい行きました
そういうことで スライドの半分が行きました
これで結論に達しました
世直しではなくて 自己直しなんですね
世と戦わないで 自分から生まれる原因を消しちゃえばいいんです
例えば 暴走族でうるさくて寝られないんですね
だったら 外の音をまるっきり遮断してくれるヘッドフォンは
あのまあ 2万程度で売ってるんで
プロのものは10万ですけど
それでも安いもんでしょ
治療を受けるよりは 暴走族に対して警察に訴えているより安いもんでしょ
買って ものすごく自分が落ち着く音楽が流してもらえば
ネットでいくらでもあるんです
3時間 4時間でも 何のことなく
なんか音楽がどうかどちらかわからない静かな音同じリズムで流れる
すると脳がすぐそれに慣れちゃうんですよ
見事に慣れると思います
それはインターナルコーススでしょ
そうすると暴走族と喧嘩する必要ないんです
暴走族と喧嘩しようと思っても殺されますからね
はい そこのところで それからインターナルコースについてちょっと休憩してから始まります
では 後半の後半の一番大事な皆さん
それ聞きたくていらっしゃったと思いますけどもね
世界はうるさいですけど
私の幸せなら簡単です
ですから 指を自分自身に刺してみる
世界に刺しちゃうと負けます
自分にさせてみると 自分はちっちゃくて大した存在じゃないんだから
不幸になる原因は自分にあるんだ
そこを直せばいいんです
えーと それでも世界が悪い
悪かったらどうしますか？っていう問題は起きません
自分を直せば 例えば二人が一緒に生活して
相手の性格が悪くて自分が困っていると
普段みんなそう思っちゃうでしょ
相手を直せないでしょうに
しかし それは相手が外の原因
困っている自分のは内の原因になりますね
いたって簡単 相手が性格悪いと誰が判断した？あなたでしょ？あなたのせい
あんた相手の性格は超可愛いと判断したらどう？すると別な気持ちになるでしょ
だから判断してた自分に問題あるでしょうに
だから自分を直せば問題起きません
相手は関係ないんです
いわゆるマッチの火が起こるためには
マッチボックスの原因もマッチ棒の原因も両方必要でしょうに
だからマッチ棒に薬 薬
なんとか火薬入ってるんだから
いたっても両方ですね
人が町を持って火をつけてやろうと思ったら
自分がマッチボックス持っているマッチボックスあげなかったらどうしますかね
火をつけることはできない
だからインターナルコースス自分の原因
直すしか科学的な正しい 100%結果出る答えはないんです
犯人捜しにちょっと戻ります
不幸は他人の原因だと一般的に思う
それで犯人捜しに協力します
犯人を裁いても自分は幸福になりません
よく犯罪 殺人事件なんか起きちゃうと
みんな大騒ぎにして早く犯人を見つけなさいとかね
でなきゃ安心して寝られませんとかね
なんかそれで警察は犯人を逮捕する
それで安心して寝る なんてバカなことですかね
また 必ず同じ問題がもっとカーになっていますけど
問題かもっと厳しい問題が起こるんです
普通そういう流れなんです
犯人を見つけて 犯人を逮捕して裁く
でも もっとひどいことが次に起こる
この性格は自分が正しいという錯覚を強化します
だから犯人が誰ですか？というと思う性格を直してほしい
それは私が正しいという錯覚がどんどん強くなるんです
自分を調整することの必要性
必要性を無視するのです
そういう時は私を調整しなきゃ
私を直さなくちゃいけないということは忘れちゃうんです
あなたは犯人だということで
それから傲慢 怒り 憎しみ
嫉妬 落ち込みなどなどたくさんなりますからが起きて
さらに不幸に苦しみに陥ります
この犯人犯人捜しに必死になっている人間が
犯人を捜して見つけて逮捕して世界幸せになったわけではなくて
どんどん怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬の塊になっちゃって
苦しい人格を作るんです
ですから 結論で言えば
あんた勘違いしている
外の原因で自分が幸せになると思うことは勘違いです
いい天気があれば いい経済状態であれば
いい仕事があればとかね
いい家族がいれば 仲間の仲間の仲のいい友達がいればとかね
幸せだという連中は一向に幸せになれません
それは勘違いです 外の原因を探すたびに
たまに見つけることができても
自分の不幸 悩み 苦しみが増幅するだけです
たまにいい仲間見つかるかも
だからといって仲間の機嫌を取らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
仲間が一緒にいたいと思う時だけ楽しいでしょうね
いつ事件が起こるかわからないでいろいろありますよ
そこで不幸へのところは
仲間がいれば幸福やと思う人の場合は成功する場合
それから成功しない場合
仲間欲しいんだけど 仲間がいない
その人は不幸のまんまでしょうに
その人を幸福にさせる方法はないでしょうに
例えば金があれば幸せだと思うってこと
だから頑張っても金儲かる場合もあるし
儲からない場合もある
仕事を見つかる場合 見つからない場合もある
だからどう解決すればいいんですかね
そんなこと言う言葉自体残酷なんです
人は金があれば幸せだとか
人はいい仕事があれば幸せだとかね
今は給料高いんだから
IT の方で能力あった方がいいやとか
こんなことすべて残酷な言葉なんです
知らないうちにダラダラダラダラと言うんだけどね
なぜならば成功できなかったらどうしますかと答えを持ってないんです
幸福になるのだと妄想して
不幸への苦しみ 苦しい道を歩んでいるのです
人類がこれやったら幸福
これやったら幸福 これやったら幸福と思って不幸になる道を歩んでいるんです
勘違いしています 原発いっぱいあれば幸せっていう話です
いくらでも電力ありますよと
そこら中作ってやろうと
だって原発の寿命っていうのは 25年
20年程度だからね 日本中作らなくちゃなりませんね
で 我々はどんな人間でも不幸になる道を歩んでいるんです
だから見事にみんな不幸です
笑う人は少ないんです
それでお釈迦様はいたってシンプルで答えるんです
あったな あったのはアベックいや
自分を観察しなさい これダンマパダの 50番目の偈なんです
その中でも一行の半分です
偈だから四行で成り立ってますよ
ですから この一行  4分の1
どうですかね すべて答え出してるんです
言葉二つで あったのはアベックいや
英語でオブザーブユアセルフ
自分を観察しなさい 他人の善し悪しを考えても
自分にとって無駄な行為になるので
自分自身を観察しなさいと説かれています
他人の世の中の善し悪しを考えたら
あんた困るでしょう だってどう手に打ちようもないんだから
最低 我が子も自分希望通りに育てられないでしょうに
我が子であっても 産んだ子供であっても
自分の言うことを聞かないでしょうに
なんでそんなことやろうとするんですかね
それが苦しみを乗り越えて幸福に達する道なのです
はい それから具体的なポイントに行きます
希望 これ 私はこの仏教説法を始めた時はかなり攻撃を受けたところで
私もそれほど経験もなくて
遠慮いっぱいあって 緊張もあって喋っていたんだから
その時は結構遠慮あって喋ったんです
歳取ったらもう頑固でね
何の遠慮もないので 言いたいことは言うんです
だって言わなかったらもう自分に先がないんだから
希望ってとっても大事なことだと全ての人間が思ってるんですよ
ヨーロッパでもね まあボーイズビーアンビシャスとか
日本の子供たちにもね
言ってるでしょ あの人
今思い出しちゃったんだけど
あの誰でしたっけ マッキントッシュの社長
えっ？スティーブジョブズ
ジョブズさん ビーハングリー
これでマッキントッシュパソコン作ったからって
大変幸せになったんですかね
性格はだらしなくてわがままでいい加減で
で がんになっちゃって
誰だって同じ道で死んでしまったでしょうに
だからいいもの残ったからといって
ジョブズさんには何も関係がないから
だから彼がいくらか日本人のお坊さんの話
日本人から仏教を聞いたってろくなことないんだけどね
まあまあ それなりの影響あって
アメリカ思考というよりちょっと違う思考をいただいて
それは金儲けに使ったんです
だからヒットしたのは
アメリカ人と同じパターンで考えてなかったからなんですね
その考えにはちょっと東洋の考えが混ざったんだから
それはヒットする商品にしたんです
それだけ 苦しんで亡くなられたんです
で 希望 希望通りに物事が動くはずありません
私は希望したからといって
自分の希望通りにいかないんですよ
あなたはすべてを支配する全知全能の神ではありません
覚えておいてください
私は全知全能の神であるというならば
あなたの希望通りにいかなくちゃいけない
日本である頭イカれた人がまんま宗教組織作ってるんだけど
自分が神様であると ブッダの生まれ変わりだと
えらいことを すべてもう世にあるいいものは全部自分で独り占めにするんです
だってみんなカモだから
何でも騙される国だからね
簡単に それで私にもそのお話を持ってきたらね
私は一つその女に言ったんです
あの人はブッダだけではなくて
神でもあるでしょ エル・カンターレでしょうにと
ああ そうですね あんたよく知っていて
言ったら あのね 当時で石油問題だったんです
今 日本はね あの石油の原油問題で困ってるんだと
経済的に だから この日本のちっちゃな小川でいいんだから
あいつ神だからね それ石油に入れ替えてくれませんかと
言ったら答えられなくて
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ
あのね 結局はあなた方の金で食ってるでしょ？神じゃと言いながら帰ってくださいと
言って追い出しちゃったんです
私は神様じゃない あれってもう人を騙して金取るためなんですよ
あれは社会的な立場を作るため
みんなに拝まれてもらいたいという精神的な病気のため
何も賢い言葉一つも語れないんです
彼のすべての本読んでも
私の今日講演で書いた内容にはかなわないんです
人の悪口やめましょう
彼の全て私は ないんです
私は悩みますよと来た女を一発で追い出しちゃったんですからね
怒ることもなく 何のこともなく無言にさせたんだからね
それで私たちは全知全能の神ではないんだから
希望通りに行くわけないんです
だって あのインチキ物語を読んでください
キリスト教でもコーランでもいいんです
聖書でも全知全能の神の話でしょ？あいつほど不幸なやつはいないでしょ
何一つの全知全能の神の希望通りにいかないんです
かわいそう 日本の皆様方は結構私に話を聞くんだけど
それぐらいの力がないんだよ
神には モーセじきじき喋ったと
誰も話聞いてないんです
だから偶像崇拝やめなさいと言ってね
だからモーセ偉そうに偶像崇拝やめなさいとかね
言って あいつはちょっとなんか森というか
なんかちょっとした崖でしょ
あの砂漠だからね ちょっと行って帰ってくると
あのユダヤ人がいると
またあの牛のでっかいあれ作って拝んでたんですね 2
日で終わっちゃう 神の命令では
大量殺人事件が起こらないと神は偉大なりと世の中知らないんですね
イスラム教の場合 ザカットではなくて
もう一つは嘘を言っていいやという
コーランに言われていたんだけどね
人を騙すためにね 嘘ばっかり言いながら
だから全知全能の神にしたって
もううまくいってない
人殺さないとイスラム教は世界一の大きい宗教にならない
女性をくたくた差別しなきゃ
神に一言で言ったら直ちに殺さなきゃ
どういうふうに恐怖感でこの腰抜けの人間を脅して宗教を広げるだけ
男と女っていうのは仲良くなるんだけど
イスラムの男と仲良くなったら
必ず相手がイスラムにならなくちゃいけない
コーランの決まりだって
日本人 結構イスラム寺になってるんですね
なんで結婚したんだから
日本人にあのお背筋がないんでしょ
あなたのコーランにそうあるんだけど
私たちの本にはそうないんだよと
私たちの本では人は自由だよと
信仰するかしないか 人の勝手だよというあれがないんですね
スパイン 背筋がないんです
はい そういうことで そんなことどうでもいいんだけど
希望は叶わないんです
私は全知全能じゃないんです
世界はあなたと他人の希望通りではなく
因果法則によって絶えず変化するんです
物事は因果法則で変化するんです
例えば私も今体がすごく弱い
私の希望じゃないんですけど
体は体勝手に衰れていく
この間病院に行って調べたら
もうものすごく激しく緑内障が広がっているんだと
機械チェックしたら 機械のデータ正しければ私の目は見えないんです
私には見えますけど で
治療もできないとかね
で それで私はがっかりしたわけじゃなくて
あ そうですか よかったねとかね
終わっちゃったんです
で 一緒に八重さんに行ったんだけど
八重さんにね 八重さん
データによると私はもう目が見えませんよと言っておいたんです
科学的なデータによると
これ検査しながら 私はこの機械の出来が良くないと感じたんですね
こういう仕組みではチェックできないんだと
そんなこと言っちゃってもね
この最新の機械でしょ
だから皆様は科学を信仰しているんだから
私は信仰していないんだからね
あ そうですか ありがとうございますとか言っちゃったね
だから私の希望は聞く必要ないでしょ
しっかり目が見えてほしいんです
眼鏡を外したいんです
若い頃と同じく 2.0 の視力が欲しいんです
希望通りになる？全知全能の神じゃないんだからね
細胞たちは勝手に因果法則によって変化していくんです
だからそれは因果法則
物事は変化する 変化するんであって
私は変化しましたではないんです
このマイクロフォンがどんどん衰えていく
私は喋ったからといって
マイクロフォンがわさわさ
こんな坊主に喋られて面白くないと早く壊れてやるぞと
それはないでしょう だから物は流れるということを理解すればどうですかね
因果法則によって誰にもどうすることもできないんだよと
希望する権利すらないのだと理解する人は幸福です
できないね 皆様には 例えば
何でしたっけ？うなぎ食べたら健康になるんだから
うなぎ うなぎ食べる日終わっちゃったっけ
で うなぎ食ったら体力があるとかね
そんな保証ある？私なんかうなぎ食っちゃってもこんなもんです
だからうなぎ食って元気になるという希望すらする権利すらないでしょ
これは食べてみてからの結果なんですね
本当はこの希望なく因果法則だと理解する人は究極に幸福なんです
それを皆さんに今は理解できない
もう一つポイントがあるんです
それは後で説明します
で 時間があったら説明します
ありのままとあってほしいまま
ブッダがありのままに見なさいと言うんです
人類があってほしいままに見るんです
あってほしいとはありえないんです
成り立たないんです だから太陽が涼しくなってくれっていう
これ希望でしょ？ありえないでしょ
だったら太陽は超熱いよってそのまま理解すれば簡単でしょうに
では ありのままを発見しましょう
ありのままは至って簡単です
なんか仏教を如実に見るって
これは修行者だけのこと
難しい くだらん 至って簡単です
物事に自分の期待 希望
好みをかぶせないだけですよ
もっと塩あった方がいいとか
もっと醤油かけた方がいいとかね
あれがありのままじゃないんです
もうちょっとこの辺はもうちょっと暖かくなった方がいいとかね
そういう 困るんですよ
例えばどなたかこちらに座っている方は
ちょっと冷房が効きすぎ
ちょっと冷たい もうちょっと暖かくしてくれと
その間で不幸でしょ あー嫌だ
私の希望は暖かくいることだとかね
それで残酷でしょ その希望は
それで一回やったんです
そういうケースは それであまりにも冷えている方
困っていると言って こちらの管理の方に喋って調整してもらったんですね
そうすると他の大勢の方々どうですかね
だから これは私に直接言ったならば
はい わかりました 直ちに手を打ちますと言って何もしないんです
なぜなら 頭イカれてることも知っているし
これは成り立たないとも知っているし
それでも私はすぐすぐやってくれますって言ったら
本人の精神状態が治るんです
それだけです あるいは逆に
ちょっと暑すぎになったかどうか分かりませんだけど
一言言っておけば そんな程度のことで解決できる問題なんです
私はそういうことを まあ結局は嘘つきことになっちゃいますからね
やりませんだけど でも
私に持ってきた問題は
私はすべて今まで解決したんです
なんでも一発で それで我々は物事を見ると見ないで何かかぶすんですよ
かぶったら見られないでしょうに
このスクリーンの上にカーテンかぶっちゃえば見えないでしょうに
あるいはプロジェクターの前に何かレンズカバーでかぶったらどうなるんですかね
それを理解してください
物事にあなたの希望をかぶせないでください
あなたの好みをかぶせないでください
それだけ もうびっくりするほど楽になるんです
何でも楽しくなるんです
例えばこのこちら花のね
まあ今はもうこれ逮捕されていますから
花は動けませんだけど
例えば 2つ 3つぐらい落ちている
差し方が甘くて それで皆様方イライラする
あれ 誰か直してとかね
かっこよく聞こえるでしょ
ダメです あれ 直せという人は苦しんでいるんです
不幸を感じているんです
微妙なところ 我々はそういう微妙な不幸もなくしたいんです
なんで自分の頭の中にあったイメージかぶせたんですかね
ちゃんと立てた花でバランスを整えて
あるイメージがあって
そのイメージ見たらニリン倒れている
ああ 嫌だな これは ってなったでしょ
ありのままっていうのは
自分の主観 自分の希望
自分の好み 対象に当てかぶさないこと
そうすると子育ても楽ちんで
家政婦の仕事も楽ちんで
主婦でしたっけ？仕事も楽ちんで
会社の仕事も楽ちんで
何も難しくならないんです
会社でちょっともうコンフランテーション
いろいろトラブルがあるんだと言って
それだったら自分の価値観をかぶせてるんです
あんた 会社の状況をありのままに見てないんです
例を出します 一応ね 手にピンクのバラの花があります
じゃあバラの花を手にとって
こんな色のね 希望は赤色
どうしますかね 自分の希望は赤色のバラが欲しいという
でももらったのはピンク色のバラなんです
不安になるでしょ？不幸になるでしょ
こんなことで だから女の子にバラの花とか差し上げる若い男たちがえらい緊張するんですよ
だってあいつらバカだから
花が好きになったら どんな花でもらった？あー嬉しいと言えばいいのに
相手の好みのバラの色の色は何なのかとかね
それで世界は嘘の世界だから
赤いバラはこんなストーリー
ピンクバラはこんなストーリーとかくだらん真っ赤な嘘でしょ
カーネーションは母親にあげるもので
母親に何か賞でも何か買ってあげたらどうですかね
カーネーションでもあれも気持ち悪いカーネーションですよ
なんでそういうくだらん妄想のストーリー作ってそれに乗っているんですかね
私もチョコレートもらったことが腹が立っちゃったんです
何考えてるんです か でお返しすると期待すいませんよ
でもあの四歳 五歳 六歳程度の女の子とか
チョコレートくれたらちゃんとお返しはしますよ
その場合はもらって楽しいし
あげて楽しいんだから
でもかえってちっちゃな子供まで真っ赤な嘘で愛するんです
それは不幸の世界なんです
日本で真面目にサンタクロースがいると親たちが子供に教えるんだから
だから大人になったらどうやって親を信頼できますかね
私は赤ちゃんというから
あんなのはヨーロッパ人のもうくだらん話だと母親に教えてもらっちゃって
サンタクロースいるっていうことは一切ちっちゃい時から信じたことがない
ちっちゃい時からバカでしょという感じでいて
全然問題ないんです いまだに
子供は誰だってやっぱりサンタクロース信仰して
映画見て サンタクロースの
歌まであるんだからね
12月になってくると決まってなんとかのなんとかの歌が流れるでしょうに
はい 希望は赤なのにに手に入ったのはピンク色のバラ
で 不満になります 赤くしようと努力する
その人は じゃあ私は赤いバラが好きだから
これなんとか赤くしようと
それで失敗するでしょ
それではさらに不幸になるでしょ
それで苦しくなるでしょ
また損するでしょ ピンク色いや
じゃあ赤いペイントスプレーやりますと
これでいい バラが自然で
涼しい触り触りがそれでいいでしょうね
これでスプレーペイントスプレーでもやったらどうなる？その瞬間で気持ち悪いものになっちゃうでしょうに
できますよ ピンク色の花を真っ赤なバラにすることは
スプレーするんです それで葉の方に入らないようにビニールで
あれ テープで留めて さーってやって赤くなっただけで大損ですね
結局は だからありのままで単純です
そのまま バラの花 はい
OK ありがとう 嬉しい
それで終わりでしょ この花はピンク色だと認識することは至って簡単ですね
それでうち あ バラの花だ
ピンク色だ 結構大きいねとかね
それって難しい？ありのまま
はい 苦しいな 問題 生きることが苦です
この絶対的な真理は変わりません
それはブッダが発見したんだから
それは生きることは苦であるということをよく理解して
発見して 証明して立証してから幸福にならなくちゃいけない
それで皆様には大きい勘違いが生まれるんです
じゃあ 話に行く前にちょっと冗談で話します
例えば ある人が瞑想して悟りに達する
一切苦しみを乗り越えた大阿羅漢になったとしましょう
苦しみはない その方に
聖者に誰かが後ろから来て
力いっぱいぶん殴る 全然痛くないね
悟っているから ありえないんです
体は苦です 殴られたら痛いんです
しかし 不幸にはなりません
それがポイントなんです
皆様の後ろから殴っちゃうと
皆様方は警察にお世話になって
裁判かけて弁償 損害賠償まで行く
戦争が起こるんです なぜならば
皆様には希望があったんです
私は殴ってはいけませんと
希望あったんだから希望が潰れたでしょ
それで苦しみが起こったんです
阿羅漢は希望がないんです
殴られたら別に希望なかったんだから
痛いな はい ああ 痛いな
なんであんた私を殴った？聞かない
これは実際にあったケースで
サーリプッタ尊者がなんであんなに落ち着いているんだか
これはありえないと あるバラモン人が
そんな落ち着いていることはできます
試してみますと言って
後ろから行って力いっぱい
サーリプッタ尊者 髪の毛を綺麗に剃ってあったんで
力いっぱい倒れるぐらい力いっぱいで殴っちゃったんで
頭に 殴ったらサーリプッタ
なんだこれはと言って振り返ってみると思ったんです
サーリプッタだから歩くスピードは全く変えないで
そのまま歩いているんです
そうすると じゃあ今さら今止まって回るでしょう
今止まって回るでしょう
行くわ 行くわ 殴られた気配すらないんです
でもサーリプッタにもそれは痛いんですよ
それでバラモン人がもうやられちゃったんで
大変なことをしました
しましたよと 確かにこの人は聖者だよと
だからさっさと走って走っていって
前に座って土下座してて懺悔すると申し訳ございませんと
えっ どういうこと？知らない
だって人が私を殴ったということに関係ない
ただ当たった 痛くなった
終わり ありのまま 何か当たった
痛みが生じた はい 終わり
それでえ？ってサーリプッタさんびっくりしちゃって
あ そういうこと なるほどな
まあいいよと 許してくれるんです
サーリプッタに私を殴ったということはなかったんです
だからサーリプッタに言わせば
ぶん殴ったからといって人には壊せませんよ
はい それでその心理なんです
生きることは苦です 皆様方は私の説法を聞いたからといって
お腹が空いたら超楽しくなるわけじゃないんです
喉が乾いたらもう幸福三昧でどうにもならないということはないんです
喉が乾いたらもう苦しいんです
しかし それによって不幸じゃないんです
これに希望を入れて楽にしようとすることが問題です
しかし 世間はそうじゃなくて
これは苦しい じゃあ楽にしようとするんです
それが間違いなんです
できません だから不幸なんです
ピンクのバラは赤くなりません
やるなよなんです だから朝から晩まで肉体を持って生きる場合は
いろんな苦しみが出てくる
長い時間経っていると私の体は疲れる
それで不幸になる必要はないんです
私は何か呪文を探す必要はないんです
3時間経っていても疲れない呪文とか
あるいは 8歳まで年取っても老いない呪文とか
二十歳の姿でいられる呪文とかないんです
あると言うなれば それは嘘です
病気になったら超気持ちよくなる
呪文はないんです そういう宗教も信仰もないんです
全知全能の神を信じる方々は病気になったら悩むんです
苦しいんです 私たちの問題はそれなんですよ
空腹は苦です 食べたら空腹の苦がなくなっただけで
空腹苦が空腹楽になったわけじゃないんです
これ科学的に見ていない
空腹になったら食べるでしょ？食べると感覚無常だから
原因変わったんだから
胃袋に何もない場合はある感覚が生じる
胃袋に何か入っちゃうと別な感覚が生じる
それだけ ご飯食べたらあー超気持ちいいって
あれは間違いの考えなんです
超気持ちいいわけじゃなくて
苦が過去の苦が消えた
それだけ その間に新たな苦が生まれているんです
次のポイントは これ幸福になる方法を教えているんです
できることをやる 家族に寝たきりの人が現れる
今よりいくつかの苦しみが増える
ありのままに見たら それはその通りです
びっくりする必要はないんです
家族に一人が年の方はもう状況が悪くなって寝たきり状態になっちゃった
だから歩いて自分でご飯を食べて
自分でお風呂に入っていた人がベッドから動けないんです
すると家族にとっては今までなかった新たな仕事がたくさん増えたんです
どうせ生きることは苦しみだから
新たに起きた苦しい仕事も行うと苦しいんです
起きてるのそれだけです
それはありのまま そうする
なんでうちではこんなこと起こるんですか？隣の家ではそういう寝たきりの人がないのに
くだらんことを希望を入れて考えてはいけないんです
それで不幸になる あるいは神様でも誰でも鬼様
鬼様でも悪魔でもいいんだから
おじいちゃんをまた歩けるようにしてください
お願いしますと ありえないです
神でも男でも悪魔でもいいんだから
この人を治して歩けるようにしてあげてくださいと
そういうケースは 0回もないんです
だからありのままに見る
ありのままに見て できることだけやる
自分にできる力ある範囲で面倒見てあげる
くたくた疲れると それなりにいろいろ政府もいろんなところでいろんな人を助けるシステムがあるでしょうね
で 週一回ぐらいホームヘルパーをお願いしてね
それで公からいくらか金が入ってくるとかね
そうやって動けば別にどうったことはない
あるいは家族に元気な人々には話し合って交代してもらったりとかね
誰もいなかったらどこかに施設にお願いするとか
だから施設とかね 政府の側がもうこんなことできませんとかね
たくさんの人がいるんだから
じゃあいいで連れてきて
こちらに置いて帰れば
私は私も年取って 私も収入がなくて
私もやっと何か食べているだけでね
あんた方面倒見ないんだったら
じゃあ置いておきますよと
もし私はお世話しないで人が死んじゃったら逮捕するでしょうにと
例えば人の面倒を見ないで家で亡くなったら
警察をかけてその人を逮捕して訴えるでしょうね
だったら政府の権利なんです
どうしても面倒を見られないならば
政府が面倒を見なくちゃいけない
そうすると政府にも言い分があります
あなたに全く家族の面倒を見ることができなかったら
我々は面倒を見てあげる
でもあなたは面倒を見なかった
だから罪を犯しちゃったんだと
そういうのなく なんだこんな屁理屈は
私ならもうなんかもう救急車でもなんでもいいんで
運んで そういう関係の窓口で置いておいて帰るんです
これあかんだったら 私に面倒見る
何か施設に入れてくださいと
だからまあ そこは余計な話かもしれませんだけど
一般の社会に戻りますよ
大体いろいろ仕事が増える
時々仕事が減る場合もある
みんな勘違いでなく 仕事が増えると
あー嫌だ あー嫌だって言ってるでしょ？例えば
ある人のをずっと 5 年間も面倒見ていた
酸素を入れ替えたり いろいろやったりしてね
で 大仕事でお風呂に入れてあげたり
体を拭いてあげたり それでその人亡くなった
亡くなったらまるっきりやることなくなっちゃって
ものすごく落ち込んじゃうんです
本当に面白いことに 今まで文句言っていたくせに
これから私はどうしましょうかと
それから新しくないです
そんなもんですよ みんな屁理屈で生きているんだから
だから私たちには寝たきりの人は立って歩かせることはできません
希望するならば キリスト教の誰かに言ってください
この間もネットで人を病気治すミラクルメッサーというサイト
セクションがあって見なかったんです
見る必要ないでしょ だから神様
バレリア あれやこれやと言って
はい 何時の病気が治って
何時の病気が治ったとかね
あんなインチキ嘘をやってもう無知な人々を騙すだけなんですよけどね
できることは完璧に行う
で 結構私の仕事をやったということで
それで充実感感じるんですね
また元気になってほしい
なんで私に限ってこんなことが起きるのかなどなど
妄想することは自分の地獄を作ることです
だから地獄を作らないでくださいなんです
がんになったらがんになったそれで終わりです
先生 何かやることありますか？と聞けばいいでしょうに
なんで私に限ってというあの一言葉で
そなた地獄を作っているんです
だから ありのままに見て
至って単純 ものすごく明るくなります
元気になります 次の我々の幸福をなくす方法っていうのは
過去と将来なんです 過去は終わった
将来はわからない 過去を参考にしたり
将来を推測したりするもの
するのも普通で構いません
過去のデータを参照する
参考にする 将来のことをちょこちょこっと推測してみる
いいんです しかし 過去に生きること
将来の中に生きることは精神病です
やってるでしょ 過去のことを思い出して
その世界で生きているんですね
病気ですよ あれは 正真正銘の
将来の夢を見て あれは子供たちにそれやるなよと言うために
ちょっとした子供たちの物語があるんですね
それは国によって物語は変えますけど
インド的な我々 私たちに教えた物語は
ある貧しい女の子がヤギ一頭飼いて
で 乳搾っちゃって ヤギにはたくさん乳がないんですよ
それを持って鍋に頭の上に持っていって歩くんですね
人生苦しい ご飯も食べてない
やっと搾った乳を全部売らなくちゃいけない
自分でも飲めない 貧しいだから
それで彼女が将来をストーリーを作るんです
はい この乳を売って いくらか金を儲かる
それから次の日も乳を売っていくらか金を儲かる
それで金が貯まったらもう一頭牛ヤギを買う
そうするとプロダクションが倍になるんだからね
乳の量が倍 そうするともっと金儲かると
それでもう一頭 もう一頭ヤギを買ってやると
それでたくさんヤギ 100頭ぐらい買っちゃうと
そうすると結構金儲かってるんだから
自分一人で仕事できんだから
お手伝い人々も頼むんだと
それで私は金持ちになっておしゃれもして
アクセサリーでもつけてかっこいい女になるんだと
するとすごいかっこいい男の人が来て
金持ちのところからお嫁にもらうでしょうと
それで金持ちと結婚して
なおさら金持ちになると
それで当然子供が生まれてきて
子供は外でゴチャゴチャ遊んでると
あ 何やってるのかと 私はちょっと子供に叱ると言って首を振ったんです
首を振ったら 頭の上にあった壺が
あれ 素焼きの壺だからね
落ちて壊れたんです だから将来の夢を見るなかれという
我々に子供の頃から教えてくれたストーリーなんです
それはいろんなバージョンがありますね
ポイと同じです 文化によって
国によってストーリーは違います
あの それは我々覚えるために
このシンハラ語でもある単語があって
それを英訳するとビルディングパレスインザスカイなんです
空にお城を作るっていう
ありえないね だから普通空にお城を作らないよと
はい それは将来 だから将来に生きていちゃうとそういうことになる
過去に生きていちゃうと
どうしてもみんな病院に運ぶ羽目になる
自分が作った怖いお化け屋敷に住むのはやめましょう
これは自分で頭の中でお化け屋敷
怖いお化け屋敷を作っているんです
作って 自分がそちらに住んで
ああ怖い ああ怖いとか
ほとんど人間そうでしょう
問題持ってきてなら過去の問題と問題を持ってきてたら将来のこと
今の問題を持ってきていたら
今の問題ないんだと だったらこのバカが死ぬまで問題ないでないでしょ
いかに他と今の瞬間で問題ありますかと聞いたらないんです
じゃあありますか？と言ったらどうですかね
今の瞬間でちょっと座りすぎちゃってお尻が痛いと
問題ですね 立て 終わりでしょ
今の瞬間でちょっと喉が渇いちゃって苦しい
外に行って何か飲んで終わり
ということは 今の瞬間にある問題にはピシッと解決策があるんです
でも我々には解決できない問題
山ほどあるでしょ ヒマラヤ 300ほどあるでしょ
富士山ほどじゃなくて
すべて嘘です っていうのは
そういう問題ないんです
そういうということは
過去に生きているんです
あるいは将来に生きているんです
現在と今の瞬間 だから答えはある
あなたは究極の幸福になりたければ現在生きてみなさいと
現在は問題ないんだよと
現在お腹がすいても問題ないんです
今の瞬間 足が椅子にぶつけて痛くなったっても問題じゃないんです
いていていと触ったら終わります
現在 犬が転がってきてちょっと怪我したっても問題じゃないんです
すぐ手当てすればいいんです
それ過去将来に持っていってください
どうなるのかと 例えばこちらに何か落ちて怪我したとしましょう
これはニュースまで残りますよ
こういうホールで設備がもう管理しないで
あれやこれやとかね これはもう 1年あるいは 2年とかね
裁判が終わるまで これは空気
空気 事業停止命令だったり
だから 100円 500
円程度手当てできたところで
もっと頑張れば もっと損害賠償で 100万ぐらいもらえるんじゃないかとか
こうやって不幸の世界を作る
そういうわけで 今現在ということは
生きることは苦だからね
いろいろ苦しみが生まれますよ
でもそういうのは問題にならない
幸福は壊さない 現在とてもシンプルです
難しいことは一つもありません
成功は当然です 現在に生きる人は成功することは当然です
それは私は瞑想を教える時はレッスン 1 で教えているんです
現在に生きる秘密を 過去将来は生きる人は仕事をさぼって不幸になる
それで過去将来に生きる人
現在の仕事をさぼっているんです
会社で過去のことを思っちゃうと仕事をさぼっているんです
将来のイメージで頭こんがらがっちゃうと仕事やってないんです
今の瞬間のそれだったらもう大失敗
生きることは今の瞬間の出来事だと経験する人は完全たる幸福に達するんです
はい 現在と今の瞬間  2つに分けたんです
皆様方は悟ってないし
瞑想もしていないし しているとは言っているのですが
あの 我々一般の方々にできるのは
今現在というところなんですね
現在も 1時間とか30分とか
今の5分とかね その時やるべきこと
例えば5分に切って この5分だけ生きてみる
やるべきことをやる というと
いたってシンプルで はい
次の5分も今のことだけやる
次の分も今のことだけやるとかね
それで瞑想する人は これを瞬間に持ってくるんです
瞬間に持ってきたら 自分は存在しない
他人は存在しないということは全部幻覚であると
それは因果法則の流れだけとわかる人にとっては究極の幸福
それはもう不動 揺らがない幸福
幸福です 世界の変化 別なタイトルです
これはいろんな方法で幸福になります
至って単純に 世は変化して流れる
それに対抗しようとすることはことほど愚かなことはありません
やってるでしょう 世は変化すると
なんとかそれをストップさせようと
こんなバカなこと 一般的に人類というのは欲しすぎなんですよ
日本でも政府でも新しい提案を出すということは至難の業なんです
なかなかこの化石人間の間で全く何もできないんです
変化 嫌だ 嫌だとかね だから変化が嫌だという人は
自分が化石になることに気づかないんですね
対抗しようとする 変わらないようにしようとする
それで大変です 世の変化と一緒に自分も変化するから困る必要はありません
だから自分も世の一部でしょう
世界も世でしょ どちらでも同じスピードで変化しているんです
何に対抗するんですかね
だから人間は進化できなくなっているんですよ
それで今  IT 時代でいろんな IT 機械とか出てきて
あーこんな変なものを触りたくない
使いたくないと思っちゃうと
その人は化石になっちゃうんですね
え？何々 今はそういう時代かと
じゃあじゃあこれ使ってみようと自分も変えれば
問題ないんで それは病気になってますけど
みんな依存症になってますからね
依存症も化石なんです
人は世の変化に自然に対応するだけです
本当は 要するに 洪水になったと
洪水やと台風が台風でしょう
それだけ 対抗する必要はないんです
まあまあ 台風で窓ガラス割れる羽目おされ
それを閉めてしっかり板でも張って食うのは構いませんだけど
ですから 世界は変化する
私も同じスピードで変化する
ですから 私っていうことは成り立たないと動いたら
その人は幸せです 幸福とは安穏
苦を楽に変えることではありません
だから歩けない人あるいは体が弱い人は車を買って車で行く
で それが幸福ではないんです
そこで金があれば幸福
なんで金がなくて今不幸
健康だったら幸福 なぜ今健康は壊れているんだから
不健康だから不幸 だから何か変えて幸福と言ったっても
これは変です なぜならば
いくら変えても変わるんだから
ストップしないんだから
キリがないんです 例えば健康にいようと死ぬまで頑張るでしょ
終わらないんですね だから頑張っただけでしょう
健康になったことないでしょ
だから不幸のままで終わる
だから幸福っていうのは
そういう金がない人に金をあげることじゃないんです
皮膚にシワがちょっと見える人にお化粧品をあげることじゃないんです
それでは問題は解決しません
とにかくシワが出る問題は解決しませんよ
変化するんだから だから安穏にいるんです
金があっても安穏にいる
金がなくても安穏にいる
食べるものはおにぎり程度しかなかったら
美味しく食べて安穏にいる
まあご馳走だったら適量食べて安穏にいる
世間に文句言わないということが
だから定義を覚えてください
幸福とは安穏であること
心が安穏 揺らがない 平穏
苦楽は現象の両面です
どんな現象も両面持ってます
感覚で言えば 苦と楽 表と裏ですね
表がないと裏は成り立ちません
だからみんなやっていることは間違いですよ
苦しみをなくして これは楽しみに入れ替えようと
入れ替えないでください
それはできない 苦しみが必要です
ご飯を美味しく感じるために空腹感が必要です
水を美味しく感じるために喉が乾いた方がよろしいんです
だからそれをそのまま
これは変えませんよ はい
早く終わりにしましょう
自我の錯覚の指令では
皆苦を楽に変えようとするが
無駄なことです 私たちには自我という錯覚があるんです
私というね 私というこの気持ちが変化しないんですね
現実だったら変化するはずなんです
錯覚だから変化しないんです 10
年前に見たのは私 赤ちゃんでいたのは私 80
歳に年取ったのも私 そこは頭がちょっとおかしい
私っていうのは錯覚です
存在しないんだから変化しないんです
兎の角ですからね 兎の角は古くなりませんよ
壊れませんよ だってないんだから
そんなのは そこで兎の角みたいな自我を持って
楽を苦しみを楽に変えようとしているんです
次 苦楽は感覚のことです
感じることで 体に感覚は無常で流れるだけです
だから美味しく感じたっても
同じものをまた食べると美味しく感じない
そんなもんですよ それを知って安穏になる
なんて美味しいご飯でしたと思わない
今美味しく感じている
でもこれぐらい食べちゃうと美味しくは感じないと
で 安穏にしてください
それが幸福というんです
で それで感覚の世界 これ飛ばして何時まででしたっけ？ 4時半ですね
もう飛んでるんですね
はい もうもう一つタイトルありませんと飛ばします
感覚の世界で まあワンチャット終わっただけで
それでもちょうど十分ぐらいかかりますので
はい それでどうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ師匠ありがとうございました
えーと 今日はちょっと時間が押してしまいましたので
質疑応答の時間は割愛させていただきます
はい では 最後の誓願で終了します
一緒に唱えましょう ドゥッカッパッターチェニドゥッカ
バヤンパッターチェニバヤ
ソーカッパッターチェニソーカ
ホントゥサンヴェーティパーニノー
苦しむものは苦しむように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
ものが悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命が幸福ごとくありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティッカー ニッバーナンパラマンワダンティーブッダ